Good, Kip, how are you?
I'm good, I'm good. So, how's it going? How was the day?
Good. We're rock and rolling. That's all I can ask for right now.
Yes.
How about you?
Good, good. It was a good day.
Yep, almost uh weekend, so just...
Waiting for the Friday.
Yes, yes, it is.
Just.
Give me back.
So, how is Sentinel doing? How is Ebner and Kristen doing?
But...
I actually just got off, I had to check in with Grayson and Abner at just about an hour ago. Checked in with them and they were, they've handled all the training modules that I gave them. They've been shadowing with
Shiraj and Santino and I will probably, I told them tomorrow morning when my team lead and I get in, we're going to look through some tickets and probably throw a couple of tickets our way and see how that goes. But yeah, I meet, I've met with them. I didn't meet with them yesterday, but Chris, my team lead did because I was in some meetings yesterday afternoon.
But we've met with him daily since Monday, so I'll meet with him again tomorrow, just to kind of, you know, do the last little of the daily check-ins, and then we're jumping over to like a weekly check-in.
Mm.
Yeah.
I can see how everything's going.
But in the week, so.
Yeah, and I was also thinking of, like, if I mean starting next week.
We can start.
assigning some tickets to them and
removing some tickets from Shiraj. For example, if we are assigning 30 tickets to Shiraj, so instead of 30, we can assign 20 to him and assign 5 each to Abner and Grayson so that they can, Shiraj can, you know, help them.
Yeah.
working on the tickets, like how to put notes, how to manage the time entries and everything.
Kip.
Chris and I have already been talking about that a little bit, starting to probably go through Siraj's assigned tickets and stuff where he's maybe just worked on it a little bit, but hasn't got over the finish line yet. Maybe throwing him over to one of those guys and letting them take over on that too, because I know...
Because...
Okay.
I know we'll probably, the goal is to get Shiraj off the account quickly. I just need, I still just need him for a little bit longer until these guys come up to speed a little bit more.
Yeah. So, I mean, my understanding is by this way, Shiraz can coach them better by, you know, taking out some time from his tickets and coaching them. Yeah.
Yep.
Any any feedback for Sentinel Web Nerk present so far?
Nope, no.
I mean, Santino's, he's still, he's doing a good job. There's, I haven't really had any concerns or anything. There was, we had that one issue, which has happened a couple of times. It's not even really, it's not necessarily even their fault, but we have what we call like co-managed resources.
Mhm.
in the system, which are our customers, but they're like, if they have like an on-site IT person. And one of the guys, one of the co-managed accounts, when...
I think it was either Sirage or Santino, when they were going and putting a ticket in their name, this co-managed resource was like the one underneath them.
So it's just like taking that extra second, like make sure you're clicking on the right thing before you hit accept or forward it over. So that's the only thing that we've had. So I talked with them about that and I sent something over to you. I know you talked to them about it and that's all we got.
Yeah.
Yeah, even I talked to them about this and they've been, they mentioned the same, like it was like one name below them, so it was a mistake.
Yep, yep, it's an honest mistake, but you know, you know how it is, just this this co-managed user was is a pretty, it's a pretty big account, so when he got the notification that he got a ticket.
Yeah.
Yes.
Mhm.
that was not his own account. He reached out to his account manager and the account manager is like, blah, blah, blah. And I'm like, hey, it's okay. Like it was an honest mistake. It's, we won't, you know, we'll work on it and build something up to where it won't happen again. And you know, honestly, I need to open up a ticket with Kaseya because
Whether it's...
co-managed account or not, I mean, they shouldn't be able to forward modify tickets to those resources. So this is one of those, I mean, it's human error. I mean, I can't get, I can't get upset about that. It's, it can happen to me. It has happened to me because I've accidentally assigned tickets to somebody else that.
Yeah.
Is right under H, so it's this is what happens.
Kip.
Yeah, I understand. Thank you for sharing the feedback and
Yeah, thank you. So I think we can quickly jump into the presentation. Let's quickly, because it's been a long time we have connected because you are out of office.
Kip.
So let me share my screen real quick.
Let me know once you are able to see my screen.
I'm able to see it.
Okay, great. So once again, welcome to our weekly business review. This is for the last week, starting April 13th till April 17th, but I have, because since it's been a few weeks we have connected, so I have collated every from the last few weeks of data into this.
PPT. So agenda would be the same. Started with check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, pay forward and recap.
And moving on to the highlights, so we have been getting good feedback from Suhrid and Sentino is also progressing well. Sentino is showing improvement. And now he is logging in four plus productive offers in daily basis. Grayson and Eben are onboarding and warm handover completed on 20th April this Monday.
And they are currently going through their respective trainings and also shadowing Suhrid at the same time. And we also received a positive CSAT survey for Suhrid and Santino for March. Thank you for sharing the same.
Course.
So, in the action tracker, Ebner and Grayson to shadow Sadhotra till 8th of May, and that is in progress, and board reviews for Sentinel, Ebner and Grayson. Well, we will keep this exercise till...
Good.
two or three months to make sure everything is progressing smoothly.
These are the KPIs we agreed on.
And let's jump into the performance analysis. This is for Sentinel's utilization for the last five weeks.
So we are seeing an upward trend. So yeah.
Kip.
So starting with 52% and now he is at 76%, which is almost at the target.
and we will keep a check on it.
So his average utilization for these five weeks had been 61%.
And this is his ticket data. So he worked on 341 tickets and close to 80, makes his closure rate at 84%.
And this is Suhrid. This is, as we have been seeing from quite a long time, it's pretty consistent. Consistently at 78% above target throughout the five weeks.
All lines up.
And this is Shiraj ticket data. He worked on 461 tickets in those five weeks and closed 308. That makes his closure at 67%.
And way forward, we will be doing board reviews with Sentinel, Grayson and Ebner to identify any process related gaps or any technical gaps. And we'll proactively try to fix them. And Suhrid is working on his level up and that will be done by the end of May and will continue to support
Sentinel, Kristen, and Aman picking up the pace and start meeting the utilization and ticket closure rate, closure target. I mean, not soon, I mean, based on the ramp up time you shared with Sentinel, so we'll try to follow the same.
Got it.
This is AI by design.
Ohh, you already aware we can skip this.
And this is the team GPS.
So, that's it.
Anything, any additional feedback?
Do you want to share?
Well, Grayson and Abe seem like they're chomping at the bit to get them some tickets. So, like I mentioned earlier, we'll get it probably a few assigned their way tomorrow, and I told them to, you know, be prepared to talk about the tickets that we're going to assign them.
on our check-in tomorrow afternoon. But yeah, well, I think we're in a good spot. I'm excited to see how these guys progress, because I know it's going to be quick.
Hang on.
Yeah, it'll be quick, I'm sure.
So yeah, let's hope for the best. And in case there are any issues, feel free to email me. I will be right there and I will get back to you as soon as possible.
You got it.
Cool.
Thank you, Adrian. Yep, thank you for joining this call. And we will keep these weekly cadence for now. In case you are unavailable or unable to join the call for some reason, yeah, just email me that you are unavailable and we can skip that.
That's good.
Gupta.
All right, so thank you, Adrian, for joining. Thank you. Bye bye.